david rawlinson is our next speaker and
his title snake robots in the wild the
earthquake in Haiti the tsunami nuclear
disaster in Japan the factory collapse
in Bangladesh scores of bombings in the
Middle East now unfortunately these are
events that have actually just occurred
in the last five years while I've been a
graduate school I in all of these
situations people were trapped below
ground sometimes just feet down but days
away from being able to be safely
reached by rescue workers during this
same time frame we've seen sensors
particularly cameras reach incredibly
small sizes and amazingly low price
points but our ability to get these
sensors to those people remain severely
limited so to access these confined
spaces deliver sensors and eight I've
been working on snake robots now these
robots are long slender machines they
have the advantage they can fit through
small openings and then once inside
snake their way around obstacles and
instruct obstructions but building the
robot is really only a small part of the
challenge the difficulty lies in its
control now this is because unlike
wheeled robots or tracked robots that
are starting to become common today
snake robots have dozens of joints and
this basically enables an infinite range
of shapes and potential motions so to
simplify their control one established
way has been to limit their motions just
two wave-like undulations but this is
both limiting and still difficult to
control so to address this issue part of
my research has worked to enable these
undulations to adapt automatically to
the robots environment so for example
now as we move through a pipe we can
push out automatically against the walls
for traction and handle the details of
negotiating a bend or a junction while
the operator just focuses on steering
the head another aspect of my research
is focused on making these controls
simple and intuitive so that somebody
without a PhD in robotics can drive
these snakes by using sensors that are
distributed throughout the robot we can
now do things like stabilize the video
from the head of the robot we can keep
the operator intuitively oriented to
their surroundings and we can even
identify and compensate for failed
components of the robot part of my work
has even actually led to defining formal
notions of up and forward for robots
that's overall shape is constant
changing to keep our research relevant
our entire research group has worked to
get out into the field as much as
possible we've made many trips to a
disaster training site Texas where we
put these robots in the hands of actual
first responders to get their feedback
in the field of industrial inspection
we've taken these robots and inspected
actual power plants both in the United
States and in Europe and we've even used
them to inspect the sewer system
underneath my advisors house here in
Pittsburgh so I know some people here
might be a little bit uneasy about the
idea of robotic snakes but my hope is
that in the very near future there will
be a lot more people that are glad to
see them thank you